bienvenidos al espacio de historia mi
nombre es álvaro cordero este 25 de
abril se celebra el día mundial contra
el paludismo esta enfermedad conocida
también como malaria afectó en 2020 a
más de 240 millones de personas de las
cuales mató a 627 mil en la crónica de
historia de esta semana repasamos la
lucha que el ser humano ha mantenido
durante siglos contra este patógeno y
como en los últimos años se han logrado
victorias parciales para controlarlo
aunque sin poder erradicarlo por
completo desde hace miles de años se
reportaron casos con síntomas similares
a la malaria en lugares tan dispersos
como el antiguo egipto mesopotamia o
china se cree que su origen está en
áfrica y que esta enfermedad ha
acompañado al ser humano desde sus
inicios como especie durante siglos se
desconoció cómo se transmitía pero a
finales del siglo 19 varios científicos
descubrieron que la causa de la
enfermedad era un parásito y que el
vector que lo contagiaba eran los
mosquitos hembra del género anopheles
la expansión de esta enfermedad se
aceleró por el comercio y la extensión
de la agricultura en todo el mundo este
tránsito hizo que en unos años esta
enfermedad afectará a una parte
importante de la población que durante
siglos careció de cualquier tipo de
remedio el primero del que se tiene
constancia es la corteza del árbol
andino conocido como cinchona utilizada
desde el siglo 16 y de la cual el
farmacéutico francés pierre joseph
pelletier y el químico josep bien ahí me
caben tu extrajeron en 1820 la quinina
que ayuda a combatir los síntomas pero
el tratamiento definitivo no llegó a
pesar de los avances científicos es por
eso que al inicio del siglo 20 se empezó
a atacar al mosquito que porta consigo
la malaria el uso de mosquiteras
insecticidas y la destrucción de lugares
potenciales de anidación de este insecto
hizo que las tasas de enfermos bajarán
especialmente en los países más
desarrollados que pudieron contar con
los mejores avances tecnológicos y un
sistema de salud fuerte
es de esta forma como en europa o en
eeuu fueron eliminando progresivamente
esta enfermedad hasta que terminó
desapareciendo por completo pero la
lucha contra la malaria fue muy desigual
en lugares como áfrica los estragos
causados durante el siglo 20 y el
comienzo del 21 son muy amplios de este
continente es originario el mosquito
portador y factores humanos como la alta
tasa de natalidad y las pésimas
condiciones de muchos de los sistemas
sanitarios favorecieron la expansión y
la mortalidad cabe recordar que los
mayores afectados por la malaria son las
personas previamente enfermas mujeres
embarazadas y los niños menores de 5
años grupos muy numerosos en la región
subsahariana
en el siguiente gráfico se puede
observar las elevadas tasas de contagios
que sufren algunos de los países a fecha
de 2018
la última reportada por la o ms el más
afectado es ruanda con casi 500 casos
por cada 1.000 habitantes es decir cerca
de la mitad de su población sufrió la
enfermedad le siguen naciones como
burkina faso malí o benin
un problema grave que se ha intentado
solucionar en los últimos 20 años
invirtiendo en salud y desarrollo una
apuesta que aunque ha arrojado
resultados positivos parciales no ha
servido para erradicar la enfermedad por
completo o bajarla a unos niveles
aceptables organizaciones como naciones
unidas la organización mundial de la
salud o las ongs han sido las
protagonistas de esta lucha pero en
muchos casos han denunciado falta de
inversión por parte de las naciones
ricas
la malaria es un asesino silencioso cada
30 segundos muere un niño de malaria en
áfrica
no podemos dejar eso así hoy tenemos
todo para prevenir la malaria y tenemos
todo para tratar la enfermedad no
tenemos excusas
para entender la situación de áfrica
basta con mirar este mapa con datos de
2018 en él se observa que los países
desarrollados del hemisferio norte y el
sur han erradicado la enfermedad en
américa latina o asia la presencia de la
enfermedad tiene tasas menores pero en
áfrica se aprecia que se concentra el
mayor número de casos especialmente en
la región subsahariana y es que las
cifras son alarmantes casi el 94 por
ciento de los casos contabilizados de
malaria pertenecen al áfrica
subsahariana aunque el 6 de octubre de
2021 el mundo recibió una buena noticia
la apruebo por primera vez una vacuna
contra la malaria durante los dos años
previos se realizaron cientos de miles
de pruebas en niños de kenia ghana y
malawi que determinaron que las dosis
desarrolladas eran totalmente efectivas
contra el parásito en 4 de cada 10 casos
y que mitigaban los síntomas en otro
porcentaje importante de long away esta
tan esperada vacuna contra la malaria es
un gran avance para la ciencia la salud
infantil y el control el área usar esta
vacuna además de las herramientas
existentes para prevenir la malaria
podría salvar decenas de miles de vidas
jóvenes cada año jiang lives y tours de
boxing y jeff esta vacuna es un regalo
para el mundo pero su valor se sentirá
más en áfrica felt most en áfrica en los
próximos años se podrá comprobar si esta
vacuna logra reducir en todo el
continente los contagios y sobre todo
los fallecidos especialmente cuando
desde 2020 se ha vivido un repunte de
casos de malaria respecto a años
anteriores desde la ms afirman que será
un camino difícil condicionado por la
ayuda que quieran brindar los países más
ricos pero mantienen la esperanza de que
se pueda erradicar el ejemplo a seguir
más reciente es el del salvador que en
febrero de 2021 la declaró extinta con
esto concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]